[Music]
science I love science
no no no no no I don't just love science
lens Siam I [ __ ] box I my name is Rick
and Morty is my favorite anime I freakin
love science
Christine Channel and Neil deGrasse
Tyson is my god
[Music]
if you've seen the legendary meme this
you've seen this meme of course you have
it's a classic one of my personal
actually it's my favorite meme of all
time I have it printed here on my wall
then you might know of the legend the
one and only neil degrasse it's because
I love science and I love Neil deGrasse
Tyson in case that wasn't clear before I
love science seriously I think Neil
deGrasse Tyson is the [ __ ] I love
science
seriously Neil deGrasse Tyson that's my
[ __ ] he's my jam
I'm like Neil feed it to me feed me the
science back man you need me to explain
Rick and Morty to your neon blue there's
no real plan RepRap science fact left
and right you probably seen Neil already
from my video where I did a Katy Perry
most people who could be born will never
be born will never even exist so the
fact that sperm neil is sort of an
evangelist for science you know it's his
job it's his career he build a career
he's an astrophysicist
but he's main career seems to be these
days to promote science to people get
people involved with silent science why
can i why do i mix that word so he goes
on these celebrity tours he goes on a
lot of public appearances and you know
it's it's a noble cost it's a good thing
you know get people involved with
science I have no problem with that but
you get you get funny moments of Oh
people wanting to understand science but
they're just they're just idiots
so the fact that sperm sure yeah yeah
weighted science the rest don't where do
they go they're dead
there's also the famous one where he
talks about time with Pharrell Williams
and time is such an interesting concept
to me like I really hate that is one of
those things that it's almost scary just
to think of the concept of time and just
because it's something infinite you
would think that's what they talk about
in this is
this interview with with Tyson and
Pharrell Williams because he has this
meme where he goes like wow and maybe
you've seen it so the Sun would rise and
said we call that a day the moon would
go around once we call that a moon we
came a month earth would go around the
Sun that became a year and these were
him the natural timekeeping ways when
you want it to be more precise than just
sunup and sundown
you had to invent some machine that
could keep more accurate time he divided
the day into parts that are convenient
to you look at Ferrell he's so ready to
have his mind blown he's like oh my god
it's coming it's coming the science fact
is coming come on Neal feed it to me
feed me the science fact we that's so we
now keep better time than that we keep a
tonic time so look at look at Farrell's
[ __ ] face and when he says that we
keep atomic time we that's so we now
keep better time than that we keep
atomic time so now we use atomic clock
and we can and you want to have totally
abandoned clock is really based on like
atoms oh yeah so now you bring them to
walk into space and you don't you no
longer have to read out this jack
it's actually based on electrons moving
within the atoms just to be precise I
don't know what frequency that is how
annoyed Neil gets from this he's just
like shut the hell up dude I don't know
what frequency that is didn't even say
anything interesting he just explained
atomic clocks is the thing he didn't
explain how it works
it's just like we use them to tell time
it's more accurate than the Sun in the
stars look even poison out himself so
you bring an atomic clock with you and
you'd keep good time and you're good to
go
yeah you are you're honking you don't
have to sit got it he's got to digest
this back Wow you just blew my mind what
that atomic time is kept by atomic
clocks
Wow you just blew my mind just blew my
mind like what why that atomic time is
kept by atomic clocks that's enough for
you to be [ __ ] mind blown on a grid
you might think of it is what's Street
in New York what street what haven't you
and what floor in a building that you
might meet someone these are three
coordinates that you it would not give a
time without a place nor would you give
a place without a time to meet someone
require four numbers basically four
coordinates three space coordinates at
one time time is the fourth dimension
isn't that a lot more interesting than
just saying this machine with houses
atoms in its name in it uses atoms to
explain tap Wow
so and this all all this this reaction
that Farrell has sort of stems from this
new cult or should I say or new movement
that embraces science as it's kind of
like weed science like whoa my mind is
totally blown right now by these science
facts main I don't know what to do about
it there's these websites like I [ __ ]
love science
oh I love science so much no you don't
you like to look at pretty pictures
or political pictures of Neil deGrasse
Tyson with quotes on it 31,000 people
liked this picture this little cartoon
image of an asteroid 400 people like
this actual science article you know
that cringe meme with Neil where he's
just like oh the crunch is too strong
it's for you okay you just don't
understand it he's correct Neil's that
Neil is cringing at you okay I think
this comic strip really explains the
whole I [ __ ] love science thing
perfectly did you know that human hair
and nails are made from the same kind of
stuff yeah I love science I'm not really
sure you understand love or science when
you love something you don't just love
the exciting and fun parts you love the
boring parts just as much as people who
truly love science spend their life
studying the tedious little bits as well
as the big flashy facts you don't love
science you're looking at the butt when
he walks by now don't get me wrong I
love Neil I think he's a very
interesting person he looks like a cute
little cuddly teddy bear and I think he
generally does a really great job at
explaining complicated things to an easy
digestible way I think that takes a
great skill and I have a lot of respect
for that but there are times that Neil
gets it wrong at least in my opinion
Neil is a very avid on Twitter he posted
in 2010 2010 another thought to disturb
a restful slumber especially if you are
vain in a mirror you can kiss yourself
only on the lips for months later
narcissists only laws of reflection
require that if you kiss yourself in a
mirror it will always be on the lips I
feel like I heard that before sometime
three years later just to FYI in a
mirror you can only kiss yourself on the
lips
another thought to disturb restful
slumber
especially if you are in vain in a marry
you can kiss yourself only on the lips
in 1927 Lindbergh flew from New York to
Paris 40 years 45 years later in 1972 we
we last walked on the moon 45 years
later in 2017 we we we but as someone
that was quick to point out we have
people living in Space Station's
there's always someone in space
constantly I hate this sort of approach
that things are better back before
things were better before man 45 years
ago things were way better man what
about the internet Neil you know the
thing that you tweet from do you
remember before the internet I do it was
awful
I understand what he meant was the
development of NASA and and in space but
come on man we're living better off than
ever
don't be so down Neil you need a hug I'd
hug you look very huggable call me let's
see what Neil's tweets if Batman wants
so badly to be a bet he might be
intriguing if like Marvel's daredevil he
were also blind like a bet bets are an
in fact not blind Neil I thought you
loved science Neil is sudde it's not a
science blow in fact for you there walk
into space I thought you were better
than this and you know what
so what Neil makes a few mistakes that's
fine everyone does I mean I never do I
never say anything wrong okay ever it
has never happened I think that what a
noise is so much is that the Internet
has collectively decided to suck Neil's
dick so hard that he's just become this
Evan Evan guy list of science it's
almost like science is a new religion
and and Neil is the Pope he has a closer
connection to science and most people
and when he speaks science he speaks it
in a way that you don't understand you
simple average jokes you don't
understand science like I do Magnemite
Neil deGrasse Tyson man am I did you
catch them how how
to ferry traveled the world that quickly
and how would she possibly know who lost
a tooth it's not just wrong but ignorant
Thank You Neil God darn it finally
someone scientifically intelligent that
can disprove this incorrect theory of
the Tooth Fairy but stay the hell away
from Santa Neil okay because we know
that scientifically proven the tooth
fairy
Nath's is wrong that's just ignorant ah
I hate ignorance I'm Neal huh there's a
thing like I said I really like Nia I
think it's really entertaining and I
think is an interesting guy to listen to
I think his mission to speak for science
is noble I just don't like this I love
science
seriously I think Neil deGrasse Tyson is
the [ __ ] and I think that's a
consequence of the kind of science that
he's promoting along with other websites
personally I hated math and I hated
physics through through the beginning of
high school but then I learned to love
it because and not because of stupid
memes about space and things to blow
your mind but because I find that it's
really really satisfying to do
problem-solving like math and it's
really really fun and satisfying to
understand have a deeper understanding
how things work in the universe and not
just superficial atoms atom clocks are
based of atoms whoa and I just don't
understand why can't you teach that
instead I really wish I learned how fun
math and physics and science can
actually be when I was younger rather
than having to discover it by chance
later and it's not gonna happen through
these stupid Facebook pages also Neil
feel free to hit me up in the DMS
anytime I'll go gay for you and MRSA
gave me a free pass